well we begin today with the tragic
story of Jacqueline call who's the
seven-year-old girl who as it is phrased
by the media died in the in the care of
Border Patrol last week of course that's
that's true in a literal and immediate
kind of sense it is it is literally true
that she died in the care of Border
Patrol but it's not necessarily true or
evidently true that she died because of
Border Patrol although that obviously is
the conclusion that the media is trying
to lead us to when they phrase it that
way in their headlines and everything
else they say so a child died in the
care Border Patrol obviously what
they're trying to insinuate what they
want you to take away from that is that
it was Border Patrol's fault
we were told last week that Jacqueline
and her father were detained along a
remote stretch of the border with about
160 other people Jacqueline died hours
later at a hospital in Texas it was
originally reported that she was
dehydrated and hadn't had anything to
eat or drink in several days the father
now disputes that he says that he he
that she was provided for he had been
feeding her making sure that she was
drinking and everything he also claims
that you know this was not a in arduous
and potentially fatal journey through
the desert and everything he's calling
for an investigation into Border Patrol
now the hospital that treated her
actually look let's let's back up for a
moment it's important to emphasize this
that a hospital was treating her
according to the story that we have now
the girl and her father were picked up
on the border originally the child did
not appear to be ill the father even
signed a form declaring her to be
healthy which is another crucial fact
now lawyers for the father are
complaining that that he didn't
understand the form because he speaks an
obscure Mayan dialect and Spanish as a
second language doesn't speak English at
all well you know I don't know if you
understood the forms or not but are we
really excel are we actually expected to
have forms in Mayan
that we can provide to the people that
come across the border if you come to a
country speaking a language that nobody
knows in this country the country that
you came to how can that be the fault of
the country that you came to well in any
case he signed the form hours later she
began vomiting was having trouble
breathing they airlifted her to a
hospital and tragically she died there
in the hospital the hospital says that
she likely died from sepsis shock which
is a condition as I understand it which
stems from inflammation in the body
causing lots of catastrophic problems
including Oregon failure now here's an
interesting though the Guatemalan consul
says that the father told him that he
has no complaints about how the Border
Patrol treated his daughter even though
the father's lawyers are calling for an
investigation according to the
Guatemalan consul the father had no
complaints according to him the father
says that that border patrol did
everything they could to save his
daughter's life
Border Patrol itself says that they did
provide water when they first detained
this group and again when she began
vomiting and was having trouble
breathing they revived her twice right
there on the spot
she got medical attention urgent medical
attention on the spot then they put her
then they they airlifted her to a
hospital where tragically she died is it
true
she hadn't been drinking or eating for
days and that's what led to this medical
emergency well that's what Border Patrol
originally said the father disputes it I
guess we don't know for sure but there
are some undisputed facts here okay I
don't think there are some aspects of
this story that are I think pretty clear
to everyone so here are the under what I
think are the undisputed facts it's
undisputed that the child was only in US
custody for a few hours so nobody is
even claiming that she was locked
somewhere being detained for days and
days and then she died which of course
would put out would put an entirely
different color on this whole situation
so that's that's undisputed it was she
was in our custody for only a few hours
they did give her medical treatment they
did fly her to a hospital nobody
disputes that they did try to save her
life nobody disputes that her dire
physical condition was not caused by
Border Patrol it was not you know she
was not abused or mistreated in a way
that would cause these problems nobody's
even claiming that I don't think any of
these facts are disputed by anyone the
only it what we know is that she was
detained she apparently was already in a
dire medical you know state even though
that was not immediately apparent and
forms were signed saying the contrary
but she was up but she was already in
that condition by the time
Border Patrol agents got to her even if
it wasn't apparent immediately now did
she get to that point being septic
because of the arduous journey across
Mexico and a lack of food and water I
don't know though it certainly would
seem to be a logical conclusion that her
physical condition must have had
something to do with the ordeal that
she'd just been through it's not to get
from Guatemala to to the US border now I
don't know I don't know how exactly they
they got there I don't know I don't
think anyone knows except for the father
and that group of people what happened
along
the way but it certainly is not an easy
journey unless you're just getting in an
airplane and flying the whole way which
we can assume they did not do so it's
not an easy journey and if a child comes
through that journey and gets to the
other end of it and is in this state
I think it's logical to conclude that
that must have had something to do with
it but the real question here is now so
we don't know in terms of the father's
culpability or did you know was he
caring for his daughter the whole way
making sure that he/she was eating and
drinking he says he was we don't know
that but the question is is there any
rebased on the information we have now
is there actually any reason at all to
think that this was the fault of Border
Patrol do we have any basis upon which
to hang that conclusion and I would say
again no but that of course has not
stopped the left from drawing these
conclusions anyway in fact there's an
editorial on the NBC News website by
Julio Varela with the title
Jaqueline calls death at the Mexico
border is our fault not her father's and
I want to read you a little bit of this
because I think it's pretty
representative of the consensus on the
left when it comes to this issue it says
a seven-year-old Guatemalan girl named
Jacqueline Amelia Rose Mary called
McKean died last week in the custody of
US Customs and Border Protection and the
Trump administration has chosen to blame
the victim and her father for the death
now that's just a lie and I've seen this
on Twitter I've seen this in social
media this well Trump and the troubled
ministration their victim blaming no
they're not nobody has blamed the girl
for her own death I have not seen that
anywhere no one in the Trump
administration has said that nobody has
blamed the girl so that is just a a
straightforward lie that's all that is
it goes on this is the nation that Trump
has created a country that continues to
dehumanize and criminalize Central
American migrants without any sense of
compassion or explanation for the root
causes of why people are fleeing their
countries in the first place even if I
were to agree with that paragraph
which I don't it has nothing at all to
do with the fact that this poor girl
died it has nothing to do with it
according to the trouble ministration
her death was her fault and it was her
dad's fault
even though government officials
confirmed that after being held for
several hours in a remote Border Patrol
station Jacqueline was put on a bus for
90 minutes to be transferred to a larger
border station for processing before
getting into any emergency medical care
for her symptoms which included vomiting
by the time a bus had stopped so had her
breathing a child is dead and the Curtin
administration shows no remorse there's
that lie again that that the Trump
administration is saying that her death
was her fault where was that said who
said that who has said that can you give
me the quote it goes on a little later
immediate care didn't really apply to
Jacqueline's situation the place where
she and her father turned themselves
into CBP had no medical care providers
and as the secretary noted wasn't
staffed to handle the 163 people who
arrived that day and the idea that
Border Patrol is some welcoming force
when migrants surrender themselves to
the agency is just not true
so what would this person have us do
what would the left have us do we have
to be equipped to handle any amount of
people anywhere on the border at any
time we have to have a team of doctors
on standby stationed across the border
ready to conduct full physicals of every
person who comes across immediately you
know I'm not making a straw man here
this is really what this person expects
this must be what they expect the family
was detained they were given a medical
survey they said they were fine they
were they were held for a few hours and
then they were put on a bus nothing
about that is unreasonable that's an
exceedingly reasonable way of dealing
with this situation if when you have a
whole group of 160 people who are trying
to cross the border illegally initially
anyway if you want to find out if any of
them are sick if there's any one all you
can do is ask them obviously you can't
you can't
perform full medical exams on all of
them right there on the spot then when
the child started vomiting she received
medical attention if you have a problem
with that chain of events if there's
something here that seems unreasonable
to you then you must really expect that
immediate and full medical attention
should be provided to everyone who
crosses the border right away no matter
where they are and no matter if they ask
for medical attention or not which of
course is crazy well the author of the
article complains that yes they did sign
forms attesting to their health but that
wasn't good enough the article says and
though the government has argued that
Jacqueline's father was asked to sign
forms attesting to their health the
fathers are the forms are presented in
English or Spanish
Jacqueline's father speaks to XG an
indigenous language of the region and
may not speak Spanish at all okay so now
we have to have forms in qeq G that's we
are required to have forms in qeq G
that's a language spoken by a few
hundred thousand people on the entire
planet Earth okay there are literally
hundreds of indigenous languages still
spoken in Central and South America
today are we supposed to have forms in
each of those languages and and how will
how are we supposed to know which
language group is crossing at which at
what time and where should border patrol
literally carry around with them at all
kinds hundreds of forms in in hundreds
of different languages and how are they
supposed to know which language form to
give to which person they don't speak
the language so I guess we're gonna need
hundreds of translators for hundreds of
languages carrying hundreds of forms
across thousands of miles of borders
that I mean that's what if you if you
are blaming Border Patrol for not having
a medical form written in a in a mostly
extinct Mayan language to give to this
family if you're blaming them that this
must really be what you expect you must
expect that they'll have a form in every
Central and South American land
that every Border Patrol agent will have
on them at all times and that obviously
is simply insane now here's the point
when you have an influx of thousands of
illegal immigrants from dozens of
countries speaking hundreds of languages
streaming across thousands of miles of
border with no regard at all for our
laws
there is just no perfect or even
near-perfect or even totally sufficient
way of dealing with the problem you know
we are being put in a literally
impossible situation so it is very easy
to sit in your house and insist that we
should have the ability to recognize if
any person who crosses the border is
sick even if they don't tell us and then
we should have the ability to
immediately provide them with medical
treatment right there on the spot in the
middle of the desert
it's easy to say that but if you
actually apply your brain to the
situation which I'm afraid the left does
not often do when it comes to the to
illegal immigration or frankly so many
other issues as well
but if you do if you just stop for a
minute to think about it think about it
on a practical level and you know and I
think that liberals often have a problem
with they are they often struggle to
think of things practically okay put all
I know you know you could sit there and
say oh it would be so nice if this and
that it would be nice it really would
but let's just think of it practically
on a on a real-world kind of basis and
if you do that you will see that though
it's easy to say that we should be
equipped everywhere and always to deal
with situations like like this one it's
easy to say that but it's actually
impossible to do we are in an impossible
situation and that's just it
and
when you're putting in an impossible
situation then it's just all you can do
is make the best of it and it sounds to
me again based on maybe there's maybe
there are details here that will change
everything and we just we haven't been
told those details maybe I kind of doubt
it but maybe all we can do is go based
on the information that we have
information that the most of which is
not actually system disputed by anyone
in fact I'm not even the Liberals who
are blaming and even after reading this
this article and and many others that
are making this case and seeing all
these liberals blaming border patrol I'm
not actually sure what it's not clear to
me what exactly they're blaming Border
Patrol for in their minds what did what
did Border Patrol do wrong what would
they have them do instead I that still
isn't clear to me you know I'm talking
about these undisputed facts what are
the disputed facts for all the leftists
what what's your point here what do you
what would you have them do can you did
you do you have a suggestion if it's not
something as crazy as the the situation
that I just outlined that will require
an army of tens of thousands of
translators carrying millions of forms
patrolling thousands of miles aboard if
that's not what you're talking about
then what are you talking about if
you're looking at this you know on again
practical terms real world how should
this have been dealt with because it
seems to me based on what we know that
it was dealt with as as well as it could
be they were given water they were asked
is anyone sick they were told no they
had to wait for a few hours for a bus to
show up there in the middle of you know
a remote stretch of of of the border
things take time so they had to wait
they put him on a bus it was only a 90
minute ride and then when it was clear
she was in a she was in a bad medical
state they they gave her treatment I
mean what else are they supposed to do
but this is the story especially when it
comes to immigration and the left that
they're full of criticisms and they're
full of complaints but they never have
any suggestions for a better way of
handling it they never do and that's the
way it always goes all right so I want
you to recall this past Halloween and
there was a raging debate online just as
there was the year before and there's a
version of this debate every year of
course but there was a there was a
raging debate about whether it was
cultural appropriation for little white
girls to wear Moana costumes
and the general feeling among many
liberals of course is that was and is
that that yes it is appropriation that
white girls should not wear Moana
costumes its appropriation for your
eight-year-old daughter to wear a Disney
costume why because Moana the fictional
character is in that fantasy world
Polynesian and if your daughter is not
Polynesian then she is appropriating a a
fictional characters ethnicity now I
want you to hold that thought in your
mind for a moment as we consider the
Miss Universe pageant last night okay
Miss Philippines I believe won the
competition but so congratulations are
but the big news the thing that got all
the attention is that Miss Spain miss
Spain was the first-ever transgender
Miss Universe contestant that is he was
the first man to compete in this women's
competition which brings me back to a
point that I feel I have to repeat ten
times a week because I just can't I I
can't help myself and I can't let them
get away with this kind of thing without
pointing out the irony and hypocrisy of
it if if appropriation is even a thing
at all then this has to be appropriation
right and this is not just a man
competing in Miss Universe this is not
just an example of appropriation the
isn't just one version of appropriation
this is quintessential appropriation
this is what the word appropriation was
invented to describe a man traipsing
around in a bikini claiming to be a
woman intruding on a female competition
in the process depriving a real woman of
the chance to be Miss Universe and also
taking the attention and spotlight away
from all the real women who are
competing Miss Philippines is not
getting all the headlines today the
headlines going to a - miss Spain who's
not even a Miss see the thing about the
kind of appropriation that your daughter
supposedly does with her Disney costume
is that she's not directly hurting or
affecting anyone okay it's not like she
dressed up as mallanna so that means
that some Polynesian girl can't okay
maybe you'd have a case maybe there
because if there was only one Moana
costume in the world just one and and a
little white girl from Nebraska scooped
it up so that a Polynesian girl couldn't
have it then maybe you would almost have
a case of appropriation there because
that's what appropriation is when when
you appropriate something you are it's
not you you're not just taking part in
it or participating because if all
you're doing is participating or taking
part then it's just participation it's
not appropriation okay there's a
difference between participation and
appropriation and so much of what we
call appropriation is actually merely
just participation it's just a person
partaking in this thing to appropriate
means that you are depriving someone
else of something that is rightfully
theirs you are taking it away from them
okay and so most of what we call
cultural appropriation is not cultural
it's not appropriation of any kind
because it's not being taken away from
anyone if a white person listens to rap
music they aren't taking anything away
from black people in fact if an
thing they're contributing they're
contributing I mean the rap industry is
is is kept afloat in large part by white
people who pay money for this music so
they're not taking anything but in this
case and with the appropriation of
womanhood so often there is something
actually being taken away from women
okay so this guy is taking is is
literally taking the place of a real
woman which means that some real woman
in Spain couldn't have that spot there
can only be four four each
I'm pretty sure this is how the beauty
pageants work right Miss Universe there
could only be one representative of each
country and presumably there are many
beauty pageants many beautiful actual
women in Spain and none of them were
allowed to be Miss Spain and compete and
for a chance to be Miss Universe because
they gave that spot to a man so
something was really being taken away
from a woman in that case and on top of
that he's also getting the media
attention which which means a bunch of
real women will not
he's appropriating some of the spotlight
and the media attention that should be
going to the winner of the competition
who's a real woman
and that's how it works with the
appropriation of womanhood that's the
difference it is real appropriation
because something is being taken from
women whether it's a spot in a beauty
pageant or it's a gold medal in a track
meet or it's privacy in the bathroom
something is being taken from women it's
not just participation if a man decides
to crossdress in his house and put on a
blouse or something and walk around
that's not I guess we wouldn't really
call that the the appropriation of
womanhood necessarily because nothing in
that private situation is being taken
from women but the moment that men
insist on actually being counted as
women publicly
and in these inin competitions and in
these formal environments and when they
insist on going into women's bathroom
women's locker room so on and so forth
now it is Pro appropriation because you
are taking something from women it may
be a better a better analogy here of
what real cultural appropriation or
ethnic or racial appropriation will be
imagine if for some reason some white
woman from Delaware was participated in
Miss Universe as as Miss Nigeria okay
imagine that it was a well I think in
that situation everybody would be that
there would be outrage across across the
world at this kind of appropriation that
this white white woman doesn't even live
in the country is you know
gets to compete and be Miss Nigeria we
would all consider that cultural
appropriation and that would really be
cultural because she's taking she is she
is taking that spot from an actual
Nigerian woman and so in that case
although very often I don't get on board
with the racial cultural appropriation
in that case I would say yeah you know
what
there's appropriation well this is the
exact same sort of thing but I would I
would argue it's even more insidious
because on top of the appropriation
there is the as I always talked about
there is the cheapening of womanhood
that happens as well with this kind of
stuff where a guy can put on a bikini
and shave his legs or whatever and walk
down the runway and we say oh it's a
woman
well on what so so that's all a woman is
to you that's what you're saying that
you're saying that that's all a woman is
all a woman is is just a a person in a
bikini and and that's it that's you know
you have reduced
hood down to a bikini which is the exact
opposite of what feminists have been
saying and arguing and supposedly
fighting for for decades now so on top
of the appropriation there is the
degradation and the cheapening of
womanhood that happens as well and you
might say that is another thing that's
being taken from woman women and so that
is another way that women are actually
being hurt by this well I don't think
anyone is actually hurt if a white frat
guy wants to put on an Ava Native
American headdress on Halloween no one
is actually being hurt by that not
nothing is being taken from anyone but
in this case people are being hurt and
something is actually being taken away
all if you're on the Left all you have
to do is just take your own principles
your own arguments just take them intact
and simply apply them to these kinds of
situations and see what happens
because when you do that you're gonna
find out that we're actually on the same
side when it come or we should be on the
same side when it comes to us of
transgender stuff all right we'll leave
it there thanks for watching everybody
thanks for listening Godspeed